hey everybody I'm Dave joined by Oscar
dais hello we are but I saw Far Cry 5 or
hiding closed doors I'm gonna talk
through what I saw obviously the most
important thing
it's boomer there's a dog dog Dave at
the start I did get to choose which
gun-for-hire I could have and I played
the demo three twice and the second time
they were like hey Jonah put you with
like a different one that's like no no
give me the dog
so ah yes basically at the start you get
like two basically two ways in the demo
at least to liberate for Zen this town
in which you progress the main story and
you can either like run in or grab ahold
sneaky sniper rifle and start stop
blinking away the nice thing about the
the dog is his ability is basically
marks everything around him he also gets
himself into a bit of trouble Naughty
Dog I was not pleased my name doesn't
show it but this guy hitting my dog yeah
that's shocking I was lazy to go to
prison for that Peter is gonna be on
he's dead down okay but the main way I
played it is sin boomer and start
opening up on fools
I don't blame me I would I'm amazed you
even got the time to actually get in
some combat if I were you I'd just like
stayed pet in the boat don't worry me
and the dog we ever said we have some
people make hangs the demolition me just
hanging out the dog avoiding the mission
hey I felt like I don't know if it's
because I'm a a on PC and I was using
the ps4 controller but I felt a little
sloppy with the aim is that when when I
was using this weapon in a sniper mode
it wasn't completely accurate that's not
me
making too much you'll just make excuses
for being terrible at video games aren't
you Dave it's still like it's still far
cry Carmack so satisfying to shoot
people to get in their face and like
stop breaking noses and stuff it's it
like it's this I don't want to say the
same fire probably combat but I mean it
very similar doesn't it it's like if it
ain't broke don't fix it right yeah I
guess I always had pretty good combat it
does feel I mean I played this same
section I think I played a sort of
shortened version of what you played
yeah I played at 83 and it does you're
right the combat I don't know something
does feel a little bit slippery doesn't
it when you're when you're moving around
with the with whatever ice all right
we've got and yeah it does feel very
very familiar but I guess like you say
it
if it ain't broke don't fix yeah I think
it might've just been something to do
with like the aim correction that
console has boomer here so that guy was
abouts an alarm boomer here rips his
throat out and just ends the mission for
me sick good boy they actually asked if
he was a guy or a girl and I the answer
I got was it's a very good little boy
okay so he's a good boy he's a very
clean so we liberate Falls and that
means we can it opens up to the
possibility of accepting missions the
tavern which one the main characters
hangs out in the spread-eagle the
innuendos are very yeah this level in
this game okay it's far cry it has to be
a daft like a daft intense game yeah I'm
competing fine with that
so can you now explore now that you've
opened up this or liberated this I post
can you just sort of go wherever you
want and chill and pepper yes look at
that there's so dog this one turned up
oh what a Labrador get lost mate can't
pet her there's also another dog when I
reloaded but I could explore from the
start but this is how you gain access to
the main missions like right okay the
people by the woman in that town was one
of the main character I can't remember
her name but she then gave me the next
main mission which was to go get a plane
and start causing a ruckus right now
it's the bobblehead oh is that my man
vas vas vas they days of like Easter
eggs I think out of all the fire cries
this one takes itself at least serious
yeah which is nice that was what I
noticed particularly about Far Cry 4
because Far Cry 4 very much felt like
Far Cry 3 but less serious a bit more
tongue-in-cheek yeah well actually I
should I just remembered Far Cry Blood
Dragon exists so it's not the second
place this guy again punch you my dog
absolutely
sealed him in right it's filled with
elements like this you save my people
who are in distress hostages that are
trying to be converted right that
increases your level what did you think
of the because I think this is the first
time that Far Cry has come to the US
this is an American setting with its in
Montana right so like what did you think
of the environment compared to that it
seems very different to what we
seen in the more exotic locations we've
seen in farcry 4 farcry 3 yeah and
previous ones like it was a refreshing
change or did it feel I really like it
it's got it's got a nice mixture of you
know I guess urban combat because
there's there's more in the way of towns
I suppose in previous why cries they're
more like shanties and villages yeah
sure it's very recognizable as stuff
that I mean if you be in America or
visit America you'd instantly recognize
a nice variation between you know just
feels and streams and forests again it's
very recognize recognizable because it's
always been you know jungles or
something
yeah so it's just going you know wearing
a different skin I guess yeah it's a
nice landscape though it looks great
especially after when I played it one
point boomers decided start chasing this
deer kills the deer then the wolf steps
up Oh what but this interaction I
thought was really cool so boomer will
actually step up to any animal enemy
that attacks you right really have to
command it to be like hey enemy please
so as soon as this wolf stepped up
boomer who is like you know 60% of the
things sighs yes bark in its face this
is like me when I come in the morning
show you so eventually the wolf is like
you know what I'm gone good guard dog
just loads of stuff like that he acts
like a dog
I'm feed it a piece of meat here the
piece of meat did however do something
else and that was I actually jumped out
of my seat with him bear turned around I
just turned around and it's in my face
that is an amazing little interaction
that you firstly you didn't feed him
meat you chucked me at his face I was
like this
the meat is technically bait and I was
like I wonder if I wonder if I can give
it to boomer everyone be like geez mate
but this bear turns up and boomer keeps
buying on the ass yeah boom just scares
the bear away as well so you're doing
precisely I wanted to see how much
boomer would do so I'm purposely laying
off the bear right okay oh yeah I
purposely being buddy the game actually
talking about I just wanted to see a
Boomer could take it down and eventually
the Bears like you know what his dog -
it's too much for me but we end up
chasing it really far the bear
eventually dies and there was a cow next
to the dead bear
it's the Boomer then decides to stop
well bull technically I guess no study I
don't know I think he just got off go up
on the wrong side of the bed because
he's getting into everyone he's faced in
a fight with everything and everyone
it'll be barking it oh I missed the
opportunity for a great pun that was
gonna say he's gonna be barking at a
tree in a minute and then I was thinking
barking up the wrong tree
and then my brain works in a weird way
this reel saved it with a really intense
wildlife as like relaxing my life the
fishing is actually a really fun this
does look at warfare nine pounds
there was actually a competition when we
were playing the demo there was a bunch
of people there and it was whoever
caught the biggest fish won a t-shirt
you know I went home that t-shirt fun oh
yeah absolutely nice biggest fish 59
pounds it's just one of the ways that
like you need things like bones and meat
and stuff to get resources right it's a
nice change from just like hunting them
I like the fact that with walking dogs
and I fishing as well farcry is slowly
turning into the dice in a mad cult
people yeah this is the guy that we need
to save torn up the plane right then
some guy it's with a baseball bat so I
gloss you know crackers crane sick this
game looks pretty good it looks like
it's come on come on a long ways yes I
played it at e3 as well like I said I
only played with boomer but if you want
to see game play with the other guns for
hire then Jess McDonald did a video on
that that should be up in the next day
or so sweet actually should be up later
today if you're watching as this is
uploaded and yeah because I didn't get
either of the other two because the
other two I got to play with them I just
didn't want to so there there's a sniper
accidentally killed Domingo nice nice
there's a sniper and there's a guy who
essentially comes and bombs everything
yeah that's the guy I'm saving the plane
right okay
yes I only got to play with boomer when
I play at e3 but did you notice any when
I play the e3 it was really rough like
the framerate was real bad I'd know
framerate drops I had no poppins it was
running on 4k it was completely playing
on PC no yes what broke up here's four
okay
yeah it was completely fine oh right to
punch this guy I died holy vengeance
coming in though the area's a little bit
too late bloomer but I appreciate the
effort so after you save him you get
Nick's plane and then I think your
mission is to you so I need to basically
start destroying the infrastructure
right and causing like heat blowing
stuff up I was really worried that the
plane would handle like super badly yeah
because a lot of console games I love
games like games that aren't you know
primarily plane games get playing
controls really really bad and even
games that are playing games and like
that sub sleep you know primarily a
playing game so I was like I was really
worried but it controls perfectly fine
it's very simplified playing controls
but if you've played anything like Ace
Combat if you've flown the planes in GTA
they'll instantly be recognizable as
you're playing controls it's very simple
it doesn't really punish you if you're
pitching or you're in the wrong way by
just decking you into the ground
mmm-hmm you can there's actually a
dogfight but these are the things we
need to give up we need sober bite put
it back yeah Eden's gate silos is what
we need to start blowing up but
eventually obviously they I felt fully
safe in the sky that's like all these
guys in pickup trucks and machine guns
they're not gonna really do much to me
yeah but no eventually they just send it
like just fighters after you right okay
that's cool can't can you so my one big
question about the plane can you have
the dog as a co-pilot no little god that
was that was one thing I was trying to
do out to cut out like five minutes of
gameplay because when I got in the truck
I really wanted the dogs just like jump
in the truck yes does he not do that he
didn't do that didn't get in the plane
but now here's the the enemy fighter
plane has turned up right to keen on me
but this this like playing that was
obviously desire
- Spray crops has got Rockets so machine
guns got bombs
you've got bomb site destroying a convoy
mean farming going on yeah from this
plane for like for just you know
farmland there's some weapons up in here
yeah this is America a heavy machinery
it really is although you do like
bombing runs I destroyed a convoy and
then it's when you're on your way to
returns a nick right but it's like like
previously in in Far Cry you had things
like you had like the gyrocopter and
stuff that you could kind of shoot from
yeah they've had vehicles previously
right but yeah
planes have never I don't think you've
ever not not to like this degree I don't
believe that you've had obviously like I
said the the gyrocopter in previous are
eyes and things like I suppose in Far
Cry primal you could you know pilot the
owl yeah now I don't know i didn't play
primal you can probably pilot mammoths
yeah any mammoths in there I love like
you can hear it now
like a proper Top Gun soundtrack kicks
in when this when this guy turns up I
love a Blood Dragon desk spin-off where
it's like Far Cry 5 Top Gun I mean you
can play it like there is fighter pilots
not fighter pilots but you know
dogfights in this yeah so I'm really
hard to machine-gun this guy and it felt
like this was when I was like okay these
plane controllers gonna hold up because
this is when I need to be really really
precise really responsive but it
controls like super well like when you
slow down you can turn tight all that
stuff like everything you'd expect from
a fully fledged playing game yeah
yeah that's it I was worried I was gonna
crash into it but overall what were your
general impressions of Far Cry given in
my opinion Far Cry has somewhat
stagnated in previous years I think for
was a little too similar to three do you
think five is a good enough a big enough
fleet leap forward from Far Cry 4 I
think so everything that you like enjoy
about playing a Far Cry game is there
and there's a bit more of it like the
exploration the hunting the environments
the I just say they kind of get a little
bit Cydia with each iteration just as
easily the silliest the story concept
this is probably the most interesting
yeah like the
the cult stuff I I wasn't like you I was
in that chuff with the previous work
right but from playing for our i-5 I'm
super excited about sweet well if you
want to see more Far Cry 5 content we've
got a bunch of videos going up on a
YouTube channel so make sure you
subscribe like the video if you enjoyed
make sure you let your thoughts known in
the comment section down below Oscar
thanks for joining me thank you very
much Dave and we will see you're a good
boy
next time I'm no boomer okay
[Music]